hey folks welcome to the Darkhorse
podcast live stream number one 99 hard
as that is to believe um it is uh
sometime mid November it is sometime mid
November it is about as mid November as
November gets the odds of November the
what of November I'm guessing from your
telling me that it's about as mid
November as you get that it must be the
Ides of November the Ides of March is
the middle of March I believe it's the
15th isn't it oh um but does that is
that what that means Ides well see now
you're putting me on the spot but I
think so yeah I don't know maybe we'll
find out I'm sure uh so here we are 199
uh we are 200th episode will be the day
before American Thanksgiving so come
back and see us then but stay here now
as long as you're here uh we're going to
talk some about the FCC and the internet
today about uh censorship the
administrative State and and more and
more more and more he a little bit of
fan mail at the end nice yeah um so join
us on locals uh where this watch party
going on right now join us on Rumble uh
join us anywhere you can find us but um
we particularly appreciate you coming
and finding us on Rumble and on locals
we're not going to be doing a Q&A today
uh we will I think next week right
before Thanksgiving um but uh lots more
to say which we will remind you of at
the end but for now let's just start off
with the ads get those out of the way
and start talking um I will say that I'm
going to read the first two of three ads
and you're going to read the last one
Brett um but just a reminder that we
choose our sponsors very carefully so if
you hear us uh talking about products or
Services when you see this green
perimeter around the screen which means
that um yes we are being paid uh for the
uh for the ads it means that we actually
really truly do badge for these products
and we do so this week's sponsors are
seed uncruise and mind Bloom our first
sponsor this week is seed a probiotic
that really works if you've tried
probiotics before and got nothing out of
it try seed it's designed differently
from other probiotics it's designed
better it actually works it does not
help with enunciation however it's not
part of what it claims to be
doing not actually what it is doing um
seed helps improve the health of your
gut microbiome which means that it
supports you becoming healthier overall
our resident gut microbes directly
impact the development and function of
the immune system even before we're born
microbes in form our immune system
teaching our body how to distinguish
between benign substances and pathogenic
antigens that is substances that our
body doesn't recognize as its own you
can support your gut immune axis in a
variety of ways including by
prioritizing sleep new research suggests
the gut microbiome has its own circadian
clock and that changes to your normal
rhythms can disrupt your microbes the
important functions they perform
prioritizing regular sleep can thus help
keep your gut immune axis healthy
another thing you can do of course to
support your gut immune axis is take
seeds DS1 daily symbiotic seed is a
plant-based Prebiotic and probiotic with
24 strains that have been clinically or
scientifically studied for their
benefits 16 of those 24 strains are
specifically geared towards digestive
health and four of the 24 probiotic
strains are known to promote healthy
skin your skin like your gut has its own
microbiome seed supports both gut and
skin Health seed is free from 14 major
classes of allergens including but
limited to sugar animal products soy
gluten peanut glyphosate Dairy shellfish
and corn and seed is basically double
hold with its capsule en capsule design
it is engineered to maintain viability
through your digestive tract until it
reaches your colon where you want it the
same design makes it resistant to oxygen
moisture and heat meaning that no
Refrigeration is necessary this means
among other things that you can travel
with it which is super useful seeds
daily symbiotic supports gut skin and
heart health and micronutrient synthesis
people who use seed often report
improvements to that adjus a function
within 24 to 48 hours so start a new
healthy habit today visit seed.com
Darkhorse and use code Darkhorse to
redeem 25% off your first month of seeds
DS1 daily symbiotic that's seed.com
seed.com Darkhorse and use code
Darkhorse
excellent we're back to onew
assessments you know there was a reason
for the one-word assessments back then
and um yeah you could even up until like
four at this point if you wanted to
you've got you've got full full vocal
range now I could even go five that is
so very
excellent five what five I was counting
as syllables rather than words yeah yeah
no we're not we're not we're not
counting syllables we don't we don't
have to resort to that sort of thing no
we do not all right our second sponsor
this week is unru small ship Adventures
un Cruise explores by sea and by land
they have boats that hold far fewer
people than most cruise boats and they
take their passengers to some of the
world's most magnificent places Panama
and Costa Rica Galapagos the Sea of
Cortez in Mexico Alaska even our own
backyard the s Juan Islands we didn't
expect to be extoling the virtues of an
adventure travel company because our
standards are very high and most
companies honestly don't come close
living up to their own hype uncruise is
the exception our years of experience
during research and and leading trips to
remote natural areas including the
scalin of Eastern Washington the Clum
River Gorge as well as the andian Paro
galpagos and the Amazon has led us to
the sad conclusion that most trips do
not meet expectations in marked contrast
uncruise exceeds expectations the small
boats of uncruise allow passengers to
get real deep experience their largest
boat can accommodate a mere 86 guests
the boats of uncruise take small groups
of people to places that larger boats
can't go and the excursions are designed
to bring people into deep nature without
destroying it when we spoke with CEO Dan
Blanchard we discovered a shared ethos
the value of wild roadless nature of
exploration and of observation our own
uncruise trip to the Inland Waters of
Southeast Alaska in early May was
fantastic we saw sea otters with their
pups mountain goats Eagles in their
nests brown and black bears puffins
orcas humpbacks Arctic turns and more
and every day we got off the boat to
hike or to kayak the crew and naturalist
guides were to a person kind
knowledgeable and enthusiastic the food
was remarkably good and food preferences
and sensitivities were handled perfectly
and every sailing with un Cruis is all
inclusive Transportation drinks Farm to
Table Cuisine daily excursions
everything is included un Cruise
understands that the boat is just a tool
their small ship cruises take guests
through communities and locals on the
ground so they can have actual
experiences unru is giving Darkhorse
listeners a fantastic deal $500 off
their current cruises an offer that you
can combine with other offers that you
may find as well so start thinking about
winter in the tropics or spring trips to
Alaska Planet trip with uncruise today
and take advantage of this great offer
go now to UNC
cru.org Pages Darkhorse once more that's
uncruise ncris e.com Pages
Darkhorse I'll bring better drive bag
next time it's Dam MH all right but I am
next time I'm bringing a better dry bag
for the camera m that was U my one
failed bit of planning on that other
something you can blame on Cru I don't
blame them for it at all in fact um it
is a testament to what a good Adventure
that was that I needed a better dry bag
for the camera because we were
constantly uh out there in the wet
confronted with Wildlife worth
photographing it was great yeah all
right
our final sponsor this week is mind
Bloom which offers a new tool to improve
your mental health at home ketamine
therapy there is no quick fix for
anxiety and depression traditional
anti-depressants don't work for everyone
and their side effects are often
devastating for some people finding a
new therapist will help or starting an
exercise routine or eating a better diet
but some people still find themselves
stuck in the darkness sometimes you need
something to unlock your brain a new way
of thinking about and seeing the world
maybe the thing that will help is guided
ketamine therapy from mind Bloom mind
Bloom is the leader in atome ketamine
therapy having safely helped thousands
of people overcome their anxiety and
depression unlike traditional talk
therapy ketamine Works quickly and
doesn't have the unpleasant side effects
of traditional anti-depressants in a
study of over 1,200 mind Bloom clients
89% reported improvements in their
anxiety and depression after only four
sessions right now mind Bloom is
offering our listeners $100 off your
first succession program when you sign
up at mind bloom.com Darkhorse and use
the promo code Darkhorse take the first
step and break free from your anxiety
and depression with mind Bloom that's
mind bloom.com m i n DBL m.com Darkhorse
and use the promo code Darkhorse at
checkout all right all
right so uh tomorrow November
15th the FCC the Federal
Federal Communications
Commission uh is going to vote to
approve or reject a sweeping new plan
for the Biden Administration a plan that
if they vote to approve would forever
change the internet and privacy therein
in the United States and presumably
would have cascading effects elsewhere
as well absolutely devastating
absolutely devastating so um our friend
Holly had a guest post on her substack
uh which links to a number of other
things we'll we'll put all of these
links in our um
in our show notes uh but the the place
probably to start is that the current
FCC commissioner Robert Carr has come
out strongly opposed to this plan uh and
I want to just read a few highlighted
sections from his uh doc his statement
dated November 6th and uh then also go
to the documents um from the FCC itself
from October 6th and October 25th I
believe and then and then let's let's
talk some so uh let's see if you can
just zoom back out on me for a minute
Zach um I got to find the stuff um it's
somehow not open where it was supposed
to
be okay here we go so this is office of
uh statement again from November 6th
from the office of commissioner Brennan
Carr uh titled Carr opposes President
Biden's plan to give the administrative
State effective control of all internet
services and infrastructure in the US
this unlawful power grab chooses Central
planning over free market
capitalism so he begins by saying um
Democrats have been uh in in charge of
the FCC and administrative agencies for
12 of the last 16 years and they have
had lots of opportunity to make changes
and uh the Biden Administration has
concluded that uh where we're at now has
not done what needs to be done and with
that car agrees um but of course he's
laying he's laying those failures at the
Democrats feet which seems fair at least
given that uh that amount of time
thought about
um he says among other things what is
this proposed plan going to do the text
of the order and I did find every single
thing that he says is in the order in
the original documents so I I know this
is accurate the text of the order
expressly provides that the FCC would be
empowered for the first time to regulate
each and every isps that's internet
service
providers Network infrastructure deploy
ment Network reliability Network
upgrades Network maintenance cons
customer premises equipment and
installation speeds capacity latency
data caps throttling pricing promotional
rates imposition of late fees
opportunity for equipment rental
installation time contract renewal terms
service termination terms and use of
customer credit and account history and
mandatory arbitration clauses pricing
deposits discounts customer service
language options credit checks marketing
or advertising contract renewal upgrades
account account termination transfer to
another covered entity and service
suspension and then in one of the best
sentences I've read in a long time he
says car says as exhausting as it is to
read that list the FCC itself says it is
not an exhaustive list fantastic use of
language there um and it's even worse
than that he says the FCC reserves and
again uh I do find this in the source
documents the FCC reserves the right
under the plan to regulate both quote
actions and omissions whether recurring
or a single instance in other words if
you take any action as a ISP you may be
liable and if you do nothing you may be
liable there is no path to complying
with this standardless
regime
and the draft FCC order says that quote
we are not explicitly tasked with
regulating entities outside the
communications industry parenthetical
aside from car a rare moment of
regulatory humility but it then goes on
to say that the FCC will do so in this
case nonetheless parenthetical aside the
moment passed the moment of regulatory
humility has passed uh quote on car
again landlords are now covered
construction crews are now covered
marketing agencies are now covered banks
are now covered the government itself is
now covered all newly regulated by the
FCC and liable for any act or commission
that the agency determines has an
impermissible impact on a consumer's
access to broadband overreach much
uh you want you wanted to add some
things I think well I just wanted to
point out that um look you're either
going to be able to handle the
contemplation that there might be
something behind this beyond what you're
supposed to see this is once again
something designed to be so boring and
uh you know technical Technical and
outside of your area of expertise that
presumably somebody uh who's more
qualified is on top of it if it's a
three-letter agency you know you want to
ignore it
right but um the there's going to be an
obvious mottin Bailey here there's going
to be a very uh defensible explanation
for why the
FCC would want to be in charge of all of
these things obviously the internet has
become essential to our daily activities
and the thought of it becoming unstable
is truly frightening if you understand
all of the various systems that depend
on it blah blah blah blah blah this
isn't about instability well this is
about inequity and access inequity and
access imagine it's not it's not about
internet instability well the question
then is is this about preventing
inequity and what the hell would that
mean or oh we have answers to that we
have
but the obvious point is it is going to
be used to create inequity which those
of us who can see you know who can read
not only between the lines but the
actual lines um can see coming a mile
away which will be denied up until the
point that it is invoked at which point
where the hell you going to discuss it
like in your backyard yeah well this
passed years ago months ago where were
you then well we were here we were here
and part of the reason we're here now is
this is going to a vote tomorrow and so
it is possible that actually getting the
attention of your representatives um you
know the links that we'll put online but
really if you if you go to commissioner
Cars Twitter account like there there
are there are easy places now where you
can go and try to get the attention of
your officials and say this this should
not pass so I wanted to suggest a rubric
it's such an obvious one you want to do
that before we finish going through this
or um yeah we might we might revisit it
but the rubric
is anything that is being proposed
should be run through the test of how
would that have worked during recent
episodes of history in other words if
you're looking at the um the wh proposed
treaty amendments um the question is oh
how would Co have gone had those
amendments been in place already in this
case we have to ask the question about
how would recent uh episodes of Internet
censorship have gone differently if the
FCC had had these controls and the
answer is it's terrifying um so anyway
that's going to be the new rubric maybe
we'll refine it a little bit but
um the very idea that the FCC wants the
power to regulate things like the
termination of accounts really whose
account will they be terminating is it
going to be I don't know ours right we
won't be able to access the internet
because we will be guilty of wrong think
yeah no and as um you know the last bit
that I read from
um the FCC grants that they're not
explicitly tasked with regulating
entities outside the communications
industry but they're going to do so
because they feel like this is important
enough that they're going to do so and
so they're they're reaching into
everything potentially it's very much
like the who in fact it's very much like
the uh proposed amendments to be uh
voted on in May of 2024 to this what was
it a 2005 who document which basically
says yeah yes technically you know
health is in our name and all that and
we're a public health you know
non-governmental body but uh really if
we say it's about public health then
it's in our it's in our domain and
therefore we are now saying that we can
say we might say we were granting
ourselves the ability to claim that
anything is within the realm of Public
Health and it's exactly the same move
that's going on here like and anything
that's outside of communications but
might impact Broadband access well then
that's our domain um I would also point
out that this very same thing uh was a
precipitating event in the collapse of
the Evergreen State College where you
may remember we once taught I do I the
Evergreen yeah yeah yeah St College yeah
and you remember I forgotten what the um
what what are you talking about what I'm
talking about is uh those who have paid
attention to that story may remember the
famous canoe meeting in which the full
absurdity of the campus went on display
you might I I actually brought I raised
the canoe meeting to a few people
recently at some of the events that
we've been at recently and um it was
brought back to them but it has faded
from memory for those of us who weren't
living the horror at the time so you
might
new meeting was an insane episode in
which the architects of a new Broad and
um Draconian plan to revamp the entirety
of the college uh to some unknown
purpose
was presented in what was called a forum
implying that we might be able to
discuss it um in fact um they hadn't
even presented it they claimed to have
emailed all of us and I had to rang the
committee to actually email it to us so
we could look at it but then we got the
day before the day before and it was uh
absurd but in any case the canoe meeting
involved a
ceremonial uh uh revelation of a one
little piece of the plan that then
caused the administrators of the college
and the members of the committee what
was the committee called I don't know I
don't know there was a large handpicked
committee um but they don't look at the
man behind the curtain committee that's
the one um they beckoned everyone to
join a ceremonial canoe that was uh
extremely it would come to stretch
across campus yes um as we uh went into
the sea of equity together anyway it was
it was an absurd uh spectal but the
thing I wanted to point to was that the
plan in fact involved them um extending
their reach beyond their uh their
Charter yes exactly um and extending
their reach into things like hiring
which they were not charged with looking
at but their point was well you're not
saying hiring isn't important are you so
obviously this is a place to um to
increase our Equity but what did they
mean by that what they meant was that
you would not be able to hire anybody
for any position including chemistry
math uh all sorts of you know uh
computer science without providing an
equity justification which meant that it
wasn't possible to hire some who was
just going to teach their discipline
they had to all be activists right no
and it it's it it wasn't what we had
seen before which was also not good
right it wasn't uh you need to write a
statement describing how you will work
towards equity in the classrooms where
you teach now this was there shall be no
positions hired that do not themselves
involve the the pursuit of equity which
means of course physics is dead and
chemistry is dead and you know
everything that isn't about this
particular ideology is dead so Equity is
you know the largest Trojan Horse of
history at some level I you know I I
think it is it was used there it's
exactly being used here because this is
being called an equity plan like that
that is the justification for this
entire FCC thing which if passed again
like with the who referendum or
memorandum or whatever it's called um
will redefine its Charter to use the
language from Evergreen to extend
borderless to you know every possible
Horizon such that it can reach into
anything that it feels like reaching
into it's um it's a sophistry super
weapon and the who explicitly um in
their revision document calls out Equity
um we talked here about the fact that
they reserve the right to uh to
redistribute the various Tech
Technologies and know how around the
world to increase the equity of a
response to a Public Health crisis same
same right so you know one might wonder
whether or not somebody didn't have a
clever idea a number of years ago that
if you wanted to actually capture all of
these structures and turn them to some
non-public spirited purpose that Equity
provides the perfect cloak because it's
ill defined and it allows you to
reorganize anything based on a claim
that something is inequitable yep right
you know and then as soon as you
challenge it the question is well what's
wrong with you are you a bigot right
right you're in favor of equity aren't
you and in fact this was this was one of
their missteps right because it turns
out Equity doesn't mean what everyone
assumes it means equity and equality are
not the same thing and we've talked
about that but I think um James Lindsay
has gone most explicitly and farthest in
terms of really laying that out in terms
of the distinction between the two and
um while it would be hard for for me to
stand up to someone and say no I'm not
in favor of equality um although there
will be conditions under which I think
that having equality as the highest or
only goal is wrong uh but Equity you
know everyone once they hear what Equity
is should be must be in fact willing to
say yeah I'm not in favor of equity nope
actually wrong uh not that that's not my
highest value it's not a value at all I
think that Equity is wrongheaded well it
is as always the result of the command
Deering of terminology
there was a point at which Equity was a
perfectly fine thing to be interested in
until it I don't know that's the
case um I I do um
Equity obviously has a valid meaning
when it is not what's the definition
that that uh that can be recovered like
what what's the valid meaning that can
be recovered there is no valid meaning
that cannot be gamed in the in the hands
of bad people but the idea that uh it
might make sense to uh reorganize
something uh you know on a on a on a
Ultimate Team for example there was a
constant process if the teams were very
lopsided of redistributing certain
players
right I guess I I need to I need to hear
the definition of equity that's being so
redistribution of talent to make
competition more interesting does not
which yes I certainly participated and
such things right uh or yeah right
redistribution of talent to make
competition more interesting when you're
playing a pickup game and the point is
the sport and the play and not that I'm
going to win at all costs um fantastic
but I don't think that that is in
service of equity but I you know until I
hear a definition of equity I can't give
you a definition that can't be gamed
because that's exactly the reason
they've settled on it is that because it
is not equality of opportunity for
example equality of opportunity we can
say are the opportunities really equal
right so the point is you don't there's
no wiggle room in there if you're
actually doing the measurement the idea
that Equity you know if you had a
um a scenario in which a group of people
was trapped in uh cold circumstances
they were threatened by cold you could
look for an equal distribution of
blankets where you could distribute them
equitably in a way that vulnerability
resulted in certain people ending up
with more blankets children who have a
greater surface area for example so
there is a legitimate version of this
but the you know nobody wants to touch
it now that we've seen what can be done
with example um yeah but anyway I think
what we're finding out is that something
whether it knew that what it was doing
on the front end when it commandeered
that term or it's just realized that the
woke revolution has carved out a huge
loophole in everything is now using it
for a power grab across public and
private uh concerns and it is resulting
in um what is obviously if you people
will remember uh we regularly invoke
William Binny uh who was with the NSA
who coined the phrase the turnkey
totalitarian state TurnKey totalitarian
state are Provisions that are erected
around you without being active so you
don't notice that it's a totalitarian
state and then somebody turns the key
this is the building of these things on
the basis that there's some problem with
the internet that needs to be rectified
and of course the FCC is going to step
in and do the job because they're just
that committed to uh our being served
well by um you know internet stuff yeah
so um before I read car's statement of
which I'm going to read one more
paragraph here I went back and read uh
the first draft from the FCC in October
6th document and then I did not read in
full but I I went through and read
several parts of it very very lengthy
October 25th document from the FCC which
is U mostly what Carr is uh responding
to here and all the quotes here from
that October 25th document which again
we'll Link in the show notes um
interestingly the October 6th the
earlier document um is almost entirely
or it it's very strongly leans on this
this
Equity uh justification for these
sweeping reforms and for this this vast
overreach um and it really doesn't come
come up much at all it's like it's
already been accepted by the time we get
to the document two three weeks later
uh and that is mostly what um you know
what I've been reading from so far but
here we have in the penultimate
paragraph of cars November 6 document
objecting to strongly objecting to uh
this plan from the Biden Administration
he writes after nearly two years and
several rounds of comments the fcc's
draft order and again this is the um the
the later the larger October 25th draft
order concludes that quote there was
little or no evidence in the agency's
record to even indicate that there has
been any intentional discrimination in
the Broadband Market within the meaning
of the statute but instead of proceeding
with forward-looking rules on that basis
the FCC at President Biden's Direction
reads an expansive and disfavored theory
of liability into the law that exists
nowhere in the statutory text even in
the absence of any evidence of
intentional discrimination the Biden
plan States the FCC can impose
potentially unbounded life ability if
the agency finds that some act or even
failure to act happen to result in a
disperate impact based on the fcc's own
judgment reading this theory of
liability into the law conflicts with
the Supreme Court's civil rights
precedent the FCC should not adopt
it and then he says look there could be
changes that would actually do some good
but this this ain't them and and this
this can't this can't go through uh I
want to read just one page of that
earlier document from the FCC which
addresses some of what he's talking
about here and then have us talk so this
is um you can show my screen here before
the Federal Communications Commission
Washington DC uh again uh from yes
October 6 so I'm just going to scroll
down to page four
here that's page three page four which
is uh part two of this October 6th FCC
document uh the subtitle of which is
digital discrimination of access must
include policies and practices that
disparately impact one or more
marginalized groups access to broadband
Services the nprm asks whether the
commission should Define digital
discrimination of access with reference
to disperate impact desperate treatment
or both Okay so we've been here before
this is this is a large part of where we
were um at ever evergrain impact
treatment are both the ntia and all the
um acronyms don't really matter here the
ntia urges the commission to include
both Concepts in its definition of
digital discrimination a Broadband
provider's practice or policy should be
deemed discriminatory if it facially
discriminates between between or among
groups or desperately impacts
marginalized groups not withstanding the
absence of any overtly disperate
treatment the core concern in this area
is the reality experienced by
individuals and communities including
whether fast reliable and affordable
high-speed internet services are made
available to them on an equal footing
with their
counterparts while disparities in
service could result from intentional
discriminatory treatment based on the
statute's protected characteristics
which should certainly be prohibited
they may more commonly result from
business decisions and institutional
behaviors that were set in motion
without any discriminatory intent indeed
isps and Industry groups have been
careful to point out the documented
evidence of disperate treatment in this
area is nearly
non-existent nevertheless marginalized
groups access to an adoption of
broadband internet service has
historically lagged behind sometimes
well behind that of other groups thus
only a definition of digal digal
discrimination that includes policies
and practices that have disperate
impacts can adequately protect less
connected
communities they're doing quite a bit of
argument argumentational bait and switch
there yeah um they say because there is
no evidence of disperate treatment and
yet we see differences therefore we have
to include disperate impacts in what
we're including in what we get to have
any say about because otherwise we don't
have any power at
all so they've created the need for
themselves um by admitting probably to
their you know despair that actually
there's no evidence of disperate
treatment oops like Verizon and T-Mobile
and you all the rest they're like
they're not actually engaging in
disperate treatment um of you know of
Rich versus not white versus black you
know any of this like there there's no
evidence of this but uh because there is
no evidence of that therefore we must
include desperate outcomes because
otherwise what are we to do what's a
poor FCC to do um I would also point out
that
Evergreen made this all so clear as well
because in that very same document they
outlined that um they would not accept
that uh that the treatment of folks
students had been equal until everyone
was equally capable on
graduation of course the only
conceivable way to do that is to hobble
people who for whatever reason even if
it's past discrimination have arrived at
Evergreen with certain skills so anyway
the point is they're just declaring it's
like declaring uh a war on terror right
you can't it doesn't end so this is
declaring a need that can't possibly be
met and therefore a Perpetual um
opportunity for meddling this it reminds
me too this is maybe going to seem a
little farther a field but it reminds me
of the Google memo memo it's not a thing
the Google memo dust up from Summer of
2017 uh where James deore then an
employee of Google was invited by Google
along with many other managers I don't
remember what his job was exactly um
software engager managers um to consider
why there might be um the skewed sex
ratio there was among software engineers
at Google and he put together a document
uh which uh you know I wrote about and I
was then on a panel with him
um and I I assessed you know what I
probably wouldn't have said some of the
stuff the way he said it but um the
science is sound and um and he's right
um more to the point though more to this
point
is you have you can't
compare you can't say ah the sex ratio
of uh Google software Engineers needs to
be the sex ratio of the population
because that's not actually the
population for from which you are
pulling software Engineers to be
employed at Google now I don't have a
perfect rubric for who you might be
pulling software engineers in Google
from um but perhaps a good proxy would
be people earning degrees either
bachelor's or Masters in Computer
Sciences uh in colleges in the years in
which people are then being hired at
Google uh so those are the stats that I
looked at in advance of the panel that I
was on with James and Peter bagoan and
Helen pluckrose in early 2018 I think
and hush sure enough sure enough the sex
ratio of uh people earning degrees in
computer science at both The Bachelor
and Master's level in and it held
whether or not you did either of those
um uh was exactly the same about four to
one male to female as the sex ratio of
software engineers at Google which tells
you that even if there is discrimination
for which there's really very little
evidence but even if there is
discrimination against female software
Engineers somewhere along the way it's
not at Google like Google is hiring the
sex ratio at exactly the ratio that the
software Engineers are being produced so
the reason that comes up here is that
the idea that the isps are going to be
responsible for disperate outcomes when
they have already been freed of the
contention that they are engaging
disperate treatment is insane it's
completely insane and and no of course
we should not all be responsible for
disperate outcomes in systems which have
all of this complexity and not that we
shouldn't try to solve these problems
but the idea that you you're providing
the service therefore you are
responsible for any disparity in outcome
even though you we've already
demonstrated that you have done really
what we could have hoped for you to have
done I would also point out I'm
done that the idea if you were going to
pick one
thing where there really was no remedy
necessary it might be
Broadband
right who lacks a damn cell phone these
days who lacks Broadband access to the
internet some homeless people have this
right this is like and in what period of
time did it become so universally
distributed no so I don't know if I'm
going to be able to find it but there's
actually a section of one of these
freaking FCC documents about
storms and their their point is which
are inequitably distributed right and
their point kind of is poor people live
in places with bad
weather and that may be true I'm not at
all convinced that it is true but that
may be
true in which case the ISP has to deal
with this the ISP is now responsible
for well the thing is so backward look
okay first of all um
let's say that you had slightly slower
access to the internet yeah it's not the
biggest tragedy in fact there's an
argument to be made it might even be
good for you well as with so many things
Co set us up for this right so what we
saw was we're going to shut down schools
to save people and then you know they
sent all the kids home and of course the
cascading and the downstream effects of
that are huge and dire um but one of the
things that we saw for sure was oh a lot
of kids actually don't have you anything
at home much you know a computer
Broadband food loving parents a bed like
anything right and so that is I'm sure
part of what allowed this thing to
happen right but we know a lot of people
don't have it it's like yeah okay true
some number of people don't and they're
also those people are also missing all
of these other things okay but even if
that were the case and I am not
convinced that there is a CR crisis
where people are lacking sufficient
access to the internet I rather suspect
the crisis is quite the opposite but
there are going to be some people
libraries do exist too Library yes
people have access right you know if you
don't have access to the cell network
you probably can get access pretty
cheaply to a Wi-Fi network there are
libraries so and the harm of not having
access you know I would like to see some
all cause mortality data on you know
internet access because it might be that
it's just actually bad for you and that
the people who have the gifts of not
being connected to it actually are going
to out compete the rest of us but
nonetheless the idea that there is a
crisis here that requires the FCC to
take a broad view about its ability to
terminate accounts did you catch that oh
yes right the termination of account yes
create Equity by terminating
accounts interesting how are you going
to create Equity I mean it's harison
haris BG on all over again right but but
the point is okay the point is some
totally garbage irrational for some
incredibly diabolical power grab on the
basis of equity which means that if you
oppose it you're a bigot it means that
you know that last tiny little fraction
of a percentage of people that really
doesn't have a good option for access to
the internet right you're against those
people yeah that's who you hate that's
why you're concerned about the fcc's
over is you hate those last few people
who aren't on the internet this is
obviously just nuts right and I would
also point out that once again the whole
idea of you know well it's not really
there's no difference between an
industry that's actually discriminating
against people which would obviously be
something in need of a remedy right
right and the impact is differential
therefore it's just as bad as if
somebody had discriminated at against
someone right is um and and we see this
over and over and over again okay well
there's no evidence of discrimination
against you know women or black people
or whatever but there's still historical
stuff which is causing the problems and
therefore therefore what like actually
finish the sentence because they never
actually finish the sentence they kind
of go like it's really bad right and no
we couldn't find any evidence of
discrimination and you know yes
discrimination still exists but most of
these stories they're like they start
with this like little parenthetical or
foot nail it's like well there's no
discrimination actually but but we got a
problem we and we deserve to have the
power to solve it well and boy do we
have some ideas for you one would have
to read especially carefully to figure
it out but I I read this document before
we came on air obious the the response
to it by car
um but I think I can read in there and
it's always the same right they carve
out a justification that could be
limited if you had some court that was
actually looking in on these decisions
on a regular basis you know it could
actually be limited in some way but the
whole thing defines its power to declare
what is a problem so broadly that you
know you couldn't possibly but you're
not being fair because you know the
internet is is a is an evolving thing
and it changes very fast and they don't
want to be limited by what we know today
they just want to they just want to get
ahead of it a little bit they just want
to get ahead of you a little bit well
they just want to get ahead of us a
little bit is exactly what I'm concerned
about because I think what I read in
there if you think back you know again
let's apply CO as the standard how would
these Powers have been used during coid
well one thing that we heard very
frequently was that the impacts of coid
were disproportionately bad for people
of color which may actually be true on
account of the fact of making vitamin D
is more difficult if you have dark skin
mhm the remedy however would have been
awareness of the vitamin D issue
supplementation of vitamin D you know
those sorts of things encouragement of
going outside right but what happens if
under this new FCC rubric the idea is oh
um medical misce and malformation is
disproportionately harming communities
of color and other oppressed people
therefore we're terminating your ISP
access to the internet so you'll stop
hurting these people it's like well that
didn't happen but it doesn't mean you
can't claim it did so you know the the
number of diabolical scenarios Powers um
the powers would be granted to the FCC
to do just that if this passes right the
FCC and we also now have the you know
the wh will presumably at some point in
the near future have these incredible
Draconian powers to declare a public
health emergency and the way these
things interface with each other is
Unthinkable if they both pass yeah if
the wh 's a a dendam passes in May and
this FCC garbage passes
tomorrow and the who has defined Public
Health as anything that they Define as
public health and the FCC has defined
Equitable access to broadband as
anything that they Define as Equitable
access to broadband which means that uh
we've got the entire universe being um
served by The Who over here and the
entire universe being served by the FCC
over here presumably there will be a
moment when they Clash when they
actually both want to make some changes
on the same thing because everything's
public health and everything is
Equitable access to broadband so what
are you going to do when these two
three-letter agencies actually butt
heads with one another I am really not
worried about that because the
that are pushing this stuff are pushing
both things simultaneously they are
going to be in complete agreement with
themselves about what it is that needs
to be done to whom when and uh yeah I'm
much more worried about um you know what
happens you think I was
worried I mean not really but uh but I
don't even think the potential um no I
think it absolutely is a potential
actually because um just like you
pointed out with regard to the Evergreen
thing uh you know they appear to be you
know like a a ragtag group of Misfits
right and it's you know it's it's it's
this group and it's this group and it's
this group and they're all saying like
we are marginalized and we are
underrepresented and we are historically
uh trodden upon and therefore we come
together and as that group starts to
grow in power uh the core members of
that group start shunting other members
out and so uh you know as as there are
fewer and fewer of us out there out here
to descent uh the the big guys will
begin to fight amongst themselves and
Sparks will fly yeah but I don't see
Sparks will fly but I don't see it
happening between these two entities
this is basically um discretion hoarding
where the ability to override reason
that might come come from any place
whether it's from doctors or from uh
bureaucrats or academics or anything the
ability to override anybody's judgment
on anything is being carved out and you
know we will find out what the emergency
is so you know yeah no doubt as uh
whatever the game is that they're
playing behind the scenes results in
people being thrown out of the
Coalition um they will nonetheless end
up in possession of all of all of the
discretion that they've
hoarded
yep
um yeah I found the stuff on Storms but
maybe it's not no I want to hear about
the storms um the inequitably
distributed storms which seems almost
certain to be
true this is again from the October 6th
document from the FCC not the most
upto-date one and a much shorter one
than the October 25th variability and
service quality might be due entirely to
a Storm's fortuitous path
fortuitous or alternatively to the
combination of that path and a
provider's practices and policies with
respect to network Investments and
upgrades if such practices and policies
are facially neutral it's facially right
that's how you pronounce that facially
it's a legal ter like on its face is
what they mean well it's a it's a legal
term anyway if such practices and
policies are facially neutral for
example based on Revenue opportunities
in different areas but lead to outages
are limitations felt disproportionately
by marginalized communities only a
disperate impact framework will allow
the commission to address and remedy
them now to really interpret this you
have to know what a disperate impact
framework is uh which sounds like
probably something the commission will
get to Define out of view of the rest of
us and then present to us uh
and you know by adopting such a
framework you know to be decided on out
of view the commission can help ensure
that providers take proactive steps to
mitigate the disparities caused by
environmental and other external factors
ensure the providers take proactive
steps to mitigate the disparities caused
by environmental
factors this is just strange and thus if
there exist areas where environmental or
other factors truly preclude feasible
provision of service the commission both
can and for the statute must account for
those factors again how like what what
are they giving themselves the right to
do and then just one more here what the
commission must not do is allow a
provider to blame geography
bad weather or other factors for a
purported inability to provide adequate
service to communities in need when the
provider's own practices and policies
also contributed to a given Gap or
disruption so at one level what I see
here is them saying um actually where
it's where it's really hard to access
like up in those
haulers uh you can't decide you ISP
can't decide not to go there you can't
decide just to do the flat lands uh
where it's easy to run lines and
really like I'm I'm surprised at that
even and that's like the the the shallow
end of this pool uh that uh the
providers I
mean this is going to seem like it's out
of nowhere you will you will understand
um people who go to the Jungle now who
aren't uh even even who are as we in in
our early days um you know we're
becoming tropical biologists but uh
we're going to jungles in Central
America and in Madagascar and we had the
sense at first like oh you know
rainforests are
steep like rainforests aren't steep the
rainforests that remain on this planet
are steep because they were logged last
rainforests are on every kind of terrain
where it's lowland and it's tropical and
it's wet right uh and you know and some
other factors around soil and and and
climate um uh work in its favor but
every place where there was rainforest
that was flat it got could
down because of the hardwoods because of
Agriculture because of Roads because of
development because it's far easier for
humans to move into flat places than
into steep places so you know that is
that is
a that is an historical truth from from
Forever that we take what's easy first
and the idea that the isps are being
required to
um to uniformly blanket an area is
interesting I'm not I I don't actually
know precisely where I fall on this but
that that is one of the things here that
I at least thought huh I I wonder to
what degree that that is agreed
upon well I mean I see a couple things
here um on the one hand you can
imagine that to the extent that there
are people who live somewhere so remote
that uh the internet can't reach them
that there's an argument to be made that
these people are hobbled in something
essential to Modern Life I don't think
that's what's going on here at all yeah
um and again I envy those people as
probably do most of us but um I also
wonder in light of what we've learned
about Mass formation if there is not
some desire to ensure that everybody's
plugged in and they're going to use an
equity justification to make sure that
they reach every last uh place so that
there's nobody left to go hey the rest
of you are all going crazy what's that
about um I would also point out this is
all a little bit interesting in light of
starlink yeah right starlink literally
puts internet broadband internet access
on boats at Sea yeah but it's not cheap
oh I'm not saying it's cheap but I'm
saying that if you wanted to make sure
that people had access um without uh
creating a fourth branch of government
right you could do it with technologies
that are already available I don't
inexpensively I don't see how that
addresses this I you know ISP through
traditional means or through starlink
it's still you know they they still the
point the point that we are being told
they are trying to make is Equitable
access and you know whatever they're
actually up to um starlink or you know
cables into your home it still it still
takes something
well no not really I mean that's the
point about the starlink is that what
you need is just power and you can be
anywhere and so but it's fantastically
expensive it's not fantastically
expensive no we're we're talking about
people who don't right but my point is a
small government program that decided to
starlink uh remote locations could do
this without creating Draconian Powers
the Draconian powers are obviously the
point well
I that feels to me like a like a like a
different point because this is not the
FCC claiming that they are now going to
start providing internet to people right
they're going to force providers to do
it they're going to force providers to
do it and so if if if right including
starlink right so um if the government
is saying oh actually we're now going to
take on and you know maybe because they
know that people would get up in arms
about the idea of like the government's
providing internet to a bunch of people
like what how is that the government's
job where do we in fact live like what
is that um but you know starlink is just
another ISP here I feel like so right
but the point is the idea of locations
so remote that they can't get internet
access which that document says should
there be such locations that it's not
just difficult but impossible um then
they at least have to account for the
causes that make it impossible actually
nowhere is impossible so to the degree
that this is um an actual concern and
that uh and that it would be good for
people uh whose you know Regional isps
don't actually get to where they
particularly live uh perhaps there would
be some good some some public good in
having those isps team up with starlink
for those particular uh for those
particular right butal my point is not
about anything other than just as it was
conspicuous when during Katrina the
government uh forgot that it had
helicopters right that it had materials
that could remedy the issues uh at a
rapid rate it is interesting that we
have a Draconian bill um with no end of
opportunities for abuse at the same
moment that we have a technological
remedy that uh interrupts the primary
justification for this right forcing
isps across the board to serve
communities equally is absurd in an era
where this could be done very
efficiently with a tiny
program I'm not convinced I I'm I'm not
convinced because that requires a a
governmental corporate alliance between
starlink and government and then um that
would appear to be competing against the
other isps like I I I feel like you get
into all sorts of legitimate regulatory
Problems by imagining that um I
do I guess I take the point that I hear
you making that I think is is quite
reasonable here as uh actually to their
point that we can't be we we refuse to
be precise about defining the the scope
of what we want to do because things are
changing so fast well yes if this
document has been in process for two
years things have changed very fast out
from under them starlink is now actually
out there and could resolve some of the
problems that they themselves are
claiming to want to solve uh by means
that are somewhat
older um yeah I don't think they haven't
noticed I I think I mean if I can just
point to one conspicuous thing here the
fact that they even mention banking in
this
document what the hell is that doing
where is it I don't remember banking in
here I can't remember but it was in one
of the quotes that you had
highlighted um not that document the uh
I working on it um but any case the idea
that they're somehow going to fix an
equity problem through regulation of
banking um
obviously strongly implies a willingness
to engage in debank and I think I think
frankly this is about control of the
internet for purposes that are not
stated it's got a justification that is
provided um yeah so the FCC doesn't
mention banking this is Carr saying the
uh the unending scope of this document
means that there are no limits and so
the particular quote is landlords are
now covered construction crews are now
covered marketing agencies are now
covered banks are now covered the
government itself is now covered all
newly regulated by the
FCC uh so you know they
just just to say it's not singled out uh
by the FCC but but his point is and as
far as you know as far as I can tell
from having read the doc the original
documents not being an expert in this at
all uh and he is he's right yep well I
think he is right and I think this is
about uh the control of the flow of
information using a uh a very thin
justification of you know the government
being obsessed with helping those small
number of people who don't have
Broadband access which is nonsense
yep okay so um again vote is tomorrow so
uh if if people feel uh inspired to
reach out to your elected officials and
make your position known that expanding
the scope of the FCC to include anything
and everything is not in the interest of
individuals or uh or anyone but the
people behind this um please do so yes
they have uh uh automated tallies so in
all likelihood you can simply call your
Congress people and you can uh have your
displeasure noted automatically it's not
hard to do and they're also um in car's
uh tweet I believe and the Washington
examiners often been cover also been
covering this um there are ways to uh
contact the FCC
directly all right so kind of related
you also want to talk about well I'm
going to let you introduce it rather
than using any keywords here yeah um my
attention was called to a Michael
shellenberger piece it's a video in
which he is looking at a 2021 video
presentation by Renee duresta on the
Stanford internet observatories
activities it create it contains some
narrative how the um the projects that
they are involved in uh came under their
purview
um it's a very it's not very long but
it's long it's 40 minutes or so and what
shellenberger does I highly recommend
the people uh watch or at least listen
to the thing what he does is he steps
through Renee desta's presentation and
he translates it as somebody who has
been uh researching um the censorship
industrial complex um that is a term
that I believe our friend Brett Swanson
is responsible for but anyway uich and
burer has brought it to much wider
attention and so Renee Desta for those
uh who don't know has been a um a
warrior of sorts
against uh what she terms mistis and Mal
information um what she's really been is
a warrior in favor of censorship who
played a a very diabolical role during
um during the pandemic I will say
um I think my first awareness of her was
from you where you uh were absolutely
alarmed at what you heard this person
say um on uh Sam Harris's podcast back
uh mid 2017 yeah yeah so she is an
unrepentant Rush Gator and I was I was
alarmed you were alarmed and I then
listened to it and it was like my
goodness a a this person is out of
control and B Sam's buying it what is
that um I will say that's not the only
place that Sam has shown himself to be
gullible turns out now as shellenberger
covers in the beginning of his video um
she has connections to the CIA which is
not terribly surprising but of course
Stanford is ostensibly private despite
the fact that a huge fraction of its
budget comes from the federal government
but anyway the these things all
become uh rather murky but I wanted to
call attention into one particular
segment of this longer video which we're
going to play and um then I want to talk
about what its implications are relative
to things we've discussed here on on
Dark Horse many times the election
Integrity partnership started in
September
2020 we had stakeholder types who could
surface instances of concern stakeholder
types so government Civil Society
platforms media so so so these are the
people that are going to be demanding
the censorship civil society and
government flagged things that were
emerging in their communities so they're
spying on their neighbors um our own
analysts did proactive detection as well
we also spied on people we created
tickets and an inkq to track the
evolution of incidents over time to see
if false or misleading claims were
gaining and reach or velocity that's the
key here so it's important to understand
that these guys are really not out to
censor every last thing they don't need
total control over the over the
discourse over the communications
environment they're looking specifically
to stop things that go viral they're
looking to stop stuff that reaches a lot
of people so that's her emphas that's
what Renee is constantly emphasizing
here and in fact it's such a main focus
that the next version of this
partnership is called the virality
project and it's specifically focused on
stopping viral narratives that result in
vaccine hesitancy there were multiple
tiers of analysis ensuring that any
particular incident or piece of content
had several pairs of eyes on it and as
analysis went on we closed the loop with
the reporting stakeholder to help ensure
that they understood the Dynamics of
whatever had inspired their concern now
sometimes these false and misleading
narratives went nowhere people are wrong
on the internet regularly and it's not a
cause for concern we don't worry about
it when people when it doesn't go viral
but okay um so I should say actually we
have um met Renee Desta at a conference
um
she sat down to breakfast with us and I
would say um superficially speaking I um
felt a thinly veiled um uh disgust on
her part I think she thinks she covers
it better than she does but I do not
have the sense of um her uh welcoming
other viewpoints I had the sense that um
we were not we were displeasing to her
but in any case that was back in um 2019
2019 yep
um what I wanted to call attention to is
something that I have previously
mentioned Under The Heading of surgical
totalitarianism and my concern is that
in the past you know if we think about
the stazzy in East Germany there was a
kind of ubiquity of totalitarianism that
was necessary to maintain control
everybody was ratting on everybody else
because they were intimidated by the
stazi into doing it and so the point is
it was no secret that this was happening
it was very visible to everybody because
everybody was feeling the pressure
surgical
totalitarianism involves the
selective application of totalitarian
tactics only where it is necessary to
prevent outcomes that are
displeasures
unfolded um I would say that a small
number of channels a small number of
people broke the public narrative which
was was being um coerced into every
mainstream Outlet was being coerced onto
doctors was being coerced into
everything so it was just simply the
water that we swam in a small number of
us caused that narrative to come apart
because we were able to get the
information into a large enough number
of Minds that people could begin to see
that safe and effective didn't mean safe
and effective that the useless repurpose
drugs were actually apparently not
useless that the um origin of the virus
was likely not uh through the wet Market
but was through the the Wuhan Institute
of
Urology um that the application of these
bizarre so-called uh vaccines was
Reckless especially um vaccinating into
an active pandemic rather than in
advance of its movement all of these
things are places where the public
became aware that what they were being
told by officials was not um accurate
and in many cases was putting them in
danger
MH if we rerun the pandemic with um
the kinds of activities that Renee
dresta here is describing and frankly
even worse in the context of the
FCC uh Power grab that we've just
discussed if you could take 10 players
off the map right if you simply reran
the pandemic but um uh Robert Malone
Peter
McCulla Joe Rogan
um um Matias Desmond you know if you
took 10 players off the map including
you and me the pandemic unfolds totally
differently right the story never breaks
people probably at this point will have
just simply accepted that the reason
that we can now all go back to life is
that these marvelous vaccines have saved
the day they will accept the phony data
that suggests um that you know they've
probably been kept out of the hospital
by these things um and you know they
would be inserted into the uh the
childhood vaccine schedule and everybody
would dutifully be getting their kids
vaccinated with them despite the fact
that that never made the slightest bit
of sense so
again if all you did was take
out um the 10 people who most impacted
the public discourse in a way that uh
went against the the mainstream
narrative then you wouldn't have to mess
with everybody else it doesn't matter
that there would be people who were
noticing things people who had you know
lost loved ones in the immediate
aftermath of being vaccinated they would
be you know shouted down by uh an angry
public that didn't want conspiracy
theories being circulated right the
calamari clots that the uh the
morticians were finding would become
just a
rumor would it's not hard to imagine
that you know messing with 10 people
would have been enough mhm and the
problem then is the idea that it had
even happened would be effectively
invisible because anybody who said hey
you have no idea what happened to us why
we were disappeared from the internet at
this um moment um well it's I mean all
all the people you mentioned were messed
with we did get messed with we just
didn't get completely obliterated right
the fact is we
um survived we
paid heavy cost but the fact that we
remained important nodes in the
discussion and staunch and staunch did
not
um did not give in to
uh true speaker why can't I think of the
writer wellan term here uh new speak new
speak true speak yeah yeah did
not continued to assess what we thought
was what what the evidence
suggested so um and true for everyone
you mentioned and many more right
besides and many more and there and
there you know I I don't the list I've
given is not complete ma nois there are
lots of people um who played an
important role in that but um so I want
to just rescue two terms one I would say
the prediction implied by the concept of
surgical totalitarianism is now clearly
true Renee Desta is talking about
surgical totalitarianism in terms
designed to make it sound cuddly but um
none Le it's obviously a real thing she
is well aware as a person who is a
central node in the censorship
industrial complex um that it doesn't
make sense to censor everybody who says
stuff that violates the mainstream
narrative what you really just need to
do is decapitate the emerging
sensemaking capacity and then people are
free to talk among themselves they can
have whatever beliefs they like um it
just doesn't threaten power um so that's
one thing surgical totalitarianism turns
out to be true right Renee d just told
you that it was
um the other thing I want to point to is
the model of goath that we have talked
about many times so just a refresher
Goliath is the force that opposes
meaningful change okay surgical
totalitarianism is one mechanism whereby
it will do that without being detectable
to most people they won't know it's
happened but what is the wh treaty
modifications the FCC power gra what are
all of these things well remember
Goliath is a composite of two things
there are honest goodness meetings
between people um the Stanford internet
Observatory and the virality project
would be a little conspiracy to you know
to shut down uh counterveiling
narratives so that's actual people who
meet but then there's also a set of
emergent properties and emergent here is
a synonym for evolved so the point is
Goliath is a is a hybrid rid of these
two things people who actively conspire
and people who are simply responding to
incentives putting something into the
world so it is a is an automatic evolved
process the reason that we beat the
narrative during coid was that the
evolved emergent part of Goliath is dumb
as long as you've got him on territory
he doesn't understand okay that's the
reason it worked and I I've used this
example before but Goliath did not know
what a p
was he didn't know why it should matter
the idea that Joe Rogan some some
fighter with a dirty man cave was going
to it's not dirty well the table is
never cleaned cluttered is not D you
should know this thing between cluttered
and dirty I certainly do I'm sorry Joe
um I I disrespected the man cave and I
I'm uh don't disrespect the manave okay
but the point is Goliath didn't know why
anything Joe Rogan thought should make
any damn difference to anyone and they
Goliath went after Joe Rogan and it
didn't work Why didn't it work right
they mocked him as a no nothing blah
blah blah blah blah that should have
been enough they had every mainstream
Channel they broadcast Joe Rogan's a
fool and all of those things and nobody
listened right but here's the
point Goliath he looks sick filter on
him yeah he looks sick filter on CNN
right but the UN punchline to the model
of Goliath which I'm going to argue is
also apparently true is that Goliath is
a dummy who can't win on territory he
doesn't understand Goliath now knows
what a podcast is this is no longer
territory he doesn't understand and he's
on the move so that the next pandemic
will not involve this play right you
can't run that play twice and expect it
to work because the next time the FCC is
going to come after you they're going to
debank you you know you'll have a you'll
be on All Digital currency you'll be
monitored the who is going to declare
you a public health Menace whatever it
is the the architecture not to lose in
the same way again is obviously on the
March
and um you know obviously the right way
to fight is to not let these things um
be uh turned into law or I'm not even
sure what the right term is in terms of
the who cuz it's above law at some level
um not allowing these upgrades to be
made to Goliath's model uh is the right
way to do it
unfortunately um a apparent defect in
human character where we can only pay
attention to one thing at a time and at
the moment we're paying attention to the
Middle East and therefore the FCC and
the who are going to be uh you know
reflashed with the brand new powers
designed to upend you know the small
number of people who actually made a
difference in the public narrative ref
flashed yeah it's just a little firmware
update just a it's just a little
firmware update you know firmware update
don't your eyes just glaze over even
hearing about it can you just deal with
it and give me back my functional exctly
give me right I I'll I'll check out the
new features and moments later I'll be
back to you know enjoying my Broadband
access that I have irrespective of what
color I might be or how oppressed my
ancestors were because everybody's got
it right um so so anyway um inequitable
Broadband access that's the real
pandemic oh good yeah that is the real
pandemic it's a public health emergency
in it is time to
[Laughter]
dance yeah well anyway so that's that's
more or less what I wanted to to extract
from that is just oh and I should also
point out that uh the the video that
Desta does that uh Michael
schellenberger now steps us through and
translates for us mhm like I said it was
2021 an interesting moment in time for
her to be focused on on these things and
you can actually see she's discussing
the transition between uh
controlling uh narratives of uh election
uh interference unfair elections and the
switch into uh coid and these people are
going to have a job no matter what the
emergency is because they're going to
have to silence people who notice the
discrepancies um but it's clearly an
Insider video this was not a meant for
the public video this was people who are
all on board with the idea that
censorship is awesome because guess
who's going to be doing it it's us yeah
right this is a video from them to them
got to love censorship when you're the
sensors gotta most people do right the
the rosian veil of ignorance would
suggest that they are um missing the
point but they do seem to have a lot of
power at the moment yep um so there it
is there it is
okay so there was uh one other large set
of topics or topic that you thought that
you wanted to talk about this week do
you still or um do you want to save it
um I guess maybe we could we could do it
quickly all right um so many of you will
have seen that Barry Weiss uh delivered
a speech at the Federalist Society um as
she points out at the beginning of that
speech that's an odd place for her to
have ended up but nonetheless she uh
gave a talk and it was it was pretty
interesting talk actually but there's
one part of it I wanted to focus on
again because it relates to um a model
that that Darkhorse viewers and
listeners um will will be familiar with
Zach do you want to play that clip
you've got the clip but that's not the
whole answer and that's because the
proliferation of
anti-Semitism as always is a
symptom when anti-Semitism moves from
the shameful Fringe into the Public
Square it is not about Jews it is never
about Jews it is about everyone else it
is about the the society or the culture
or the country where it is being allowed
to
proliferate
anti-Semitism is a warning system it is
it is a sign that the society itself is
breaking down that it is
dying it is symptom of a much deeper
crisis one that explains how in the span
of a little over 20 years since
September 11th educated people Now
respond to an act of savagery not with a
defense of
civilization but with a defense of
barbarism all right so I don't actually
know uh whether bar has seen any of our
discussion on why economic contraction
should be related to the the outbreaks
of anti-Semitism doesn't really matter
she points to the pattern um that
economic contraction does seem to lead
to this and so uh I like her framing
which is that you know anti-Semitism
isn't really about Jews it's about other
people having a different relationship
to Jews a uh Angry distrustful one and
that that is a measure of the health of
a society I think that's dead on
accurate um but she doesn't get to why
that relationship uh exist which we've
talked about um here a number of times
we've talked about lineage versus
lineage competition and the fact that
Jews living as a diaspora are
effectively always vulnerable that
because Jews have a um a history of
existing uh in highly functional
relationships with other societies where
they are always a minority um have a
toolkit that works well in these
contexts so that not only only are they
vulnerable because they are embedded in
other societies um but they also often
have resources so at the point of econ
economic contraction When leaders are
struggling for a way to keep people from
uh revolting over the uh reduction in
the quality of their well-being deciding
on a Target that has some resources and
the ability to create phony growth by um
purging those people is a uh a perennial
strategy and so so Weiss's Point here um
that at A Moment Like This where you're
suddenly seeing an outbreak of
anti-Semitism it's telling you something
about the health of your Society that's
um that's a very uh significant and
important
point I had two other things I wanted to
say maybe it's just one important one
which
is I don't I still see a lot of claims
by people that there is no uptick in
anti-Semitism still yeah post October
7th oh yeah um now from Wow incredible
people um now I don't know exactly how
they get there I think there are two
ways one so okay I haven't seen
this my first thought is no it's always
been there you're just seeing it now
that's the sophisticated right right and
there's an argument to be made that I
don't think this is accurate I think
actually um for one thing you know it's
sort of the far-left
uh naive T about the
way cognitive development
works right so forgive forgive the weird
connection here but there's a way that
those on the far left who are pushing a
certain perspective on how we are all to
interact want to take our defects and
assume that if you've got them that they
are just simply god-given
right yeah um true they do and this I
mean this is related to the focus on
identity rather than meaning which we've
talked about before this move to like oh
the most important thing I can do is
figure out what my identity is like that
can change right that can CH you should
want that to be able to change why are
you so focused on this as a permanent
part of your personality that can change
and one of the ways that it does change
is that when you want things that aren't
okay civilization has ways of letting
you know and then the fact that you
don't get a reward down that pathway but
a punishment causes you to evolve into a
better person yeah um so I don't think
it is true that the anti-Semitism was
always there and you're just seeing it
that's certainly true of some fraction
of it but there's a it is it is true for
instance like we know for sure that
higher ed hides a like cloaks houses a
lot of anti-Semitism that if you are on
the outside if you went to college a
long time ago or if you didn't um it may
shock you to learn that the following
two things are both true uh that uh Jews
are over represented on the faculty of
uh universities and colleges um compared
to their representation of the
population and also that their rate that
the anti-Semitism that is tolerated and
that is spoken on campuses of higher
education is way higher than you would
hear in the Public Square in the media
like you know until until post October
7th um you know campus were a place
where you could reliably get uh
anti-semitic protests and have people be
like yeah cool they're just it's a it's
a strange it's a strange inconsistency
that has been true in higher at least at
least since we were in college in the
early 90s y yeah um it's there so
there's let's say that there's some
fraction of it I don't know what the
fraction is but there's some fraction of
it that is uncovered by the fact that we
are now a focused across civilization on
things that you know involve of Israel
and therefore an implied implication
across all Jews um but there is also the
fact of some people who don't have these
instincts are now hearing that
anti-semitic conversation taking place
around them they're hearing the way it
is done that allows you to stick on just
this side of some line it's normalizing
right it's normalizing and as it
normalizes lots of people who wouldn't
be trafficking this stuff are
experimenting with it or you know if
they were experimenting with it before
at some level they're now experimenting
it with it at a higher level so I don't
think that is just an uncovering I think
that that's actually a tremendous uptick
in anti-Semitism and viewers of this
podcast will also know that we were
talking about this uh alarming uptick
before October 7th we were talking You'
you've been seeing it um you've been
seeing it for quite some time I've been
seeing it and I will also just draw a
connection for people who who don't
realize it the thing that brought me to
public attention me trying to reason
with students about their view inent on
a clubhouse where I was in a uh a room
and there was an eruption of racial
tension I was just simply trying to
participate in the conversation and I
got challenged in fact because I'm
Jewish they declared me not white but
spicy whatever the hell that means um
these people they jewi they have not had
Jewish food I think but um
anyway I do love some H talk but anyway
lkas good food but spicy it ain't spicy
it ain't but so there's this there is
this uptick both in the visibility the
acceptability of anti-Semitism but also
the degree to which uh resentments that
bubble up during an economic contraction
are on people's minds it's just there
and if you're not seeing it yet it's cuz
you're not in the right places so go
take a look you'll find it it's there it
comes in a bunch of different flavors
um on the other hand there is also at
this moment something that I think is
historically unique on the other side
too the number of people who at this
moment where there is this uh outbreak
of over anti-Semitism across
civilization there are an awful lot of
people standing up and resisting it
people who are not Jewish who are saying
this is
unacceptable and uh you know on the one
hand I I rather suspect that the um the
period of relative calm in which uh Jews
didn't have to worry so much about the
this traveling most of the world I think
those days are probably over and I don't
think I don't think we or our children
are likely to live to see them
restored um that said it's a very it's
not history repeating itself it's a very
different version of events with um the
number of
uh well-positioned people who are not
putting up with it uh who are uh
standing shoulder-to-shoulder
uh with with the Jews and their lives
and so anyway I don't know how this all
works out um I think it was it was
insane to allow this to Fester the way
we did and as always happens when you
allow these things to Fester ultimately
you pay a much higher price um when they
finally break out into the open um but
anyway I am I am grateful to see uh lots
of folks standing up against it and and
and not putting up with it well this um
I thought I'd show this
uh th that I've called piece of fan mail
and it's really quite the opposite um in
the wake of you talking about this it
seems a little bit um wrong now but I
but I I think
it's I think it's actually appropriate
you haven't seen it um we actually get a
ton of don't show yeah we we get we get
a lot of great um mail and packages and
books and stuff from people um but a lot
of great letters um and we get you know
especially since we were traveling just
now for me for almost three weeks we
just hear from so many people and it's
it's very very meaningful um and I think
there's been
once um for each of us that we were
actually approached by a hater uh and
had a public uh
conflagration um and we're not going to
go into either of those right now but um
literally once among hundreds but
probably more than a thousand
interactions in public at this point um
and the ratio more or less holds in
terms of what we receive uh virtually um
but um and you know we don't we don't
get hate to our to our emails really but
reviews are Anonymous and easy to make
so I saw this review uh come through
this week about the podcast dangerously
stupid this podcast kills people one
star people have literally died because
of the misinformation on vaccines and
icon spread by this podcast Apple needs
to remove it call Brett what you will
Chaos Agent Peter Teal's puppet
sociopath mad agent wow what is
absolutely clear is the man has an
unwell mind and he wants to influence
yours run yeah
so I just found
that I mean honestly delightful at one
level because it so
encapsulates the inanity like I I don't
even know maybe this isn't to even a
real person right um or it's a real
person but it's someone who's been paid
to put this sort of thing out there and
all of the on all of the people's
platforms who
are they he snuck he it they snuck in
snuck in the little um you know Zionist
bit there right Massad agent Massad
agent yeah that's that's a good one um I
will point out there was an exchange on
Twitter in which
um somebody had also said something
incredibly uh Stupid about me um and uh
uh Gator our friend um who is not in
fact an animated crocodile we don't know
that you do yeah I I do too yeah
um well not animated cartoon cartoon
yeah animation but anyway he pointed out
that um while the person uh writing this
um scathing declaration about me was
obviously a at least he spelled my
name correctly um uh uh to which
alexandros marinos pointed out that that
actually likely implied that it was a
bot and then on looking at the profile
of the person it was pretty clear it was
not a real honest to goodness person
this also contained a correct spelling
of my name thereby indicating that that
may have been automated having just
copied my name from whatever it was that
um triggered the scaling review but
anyway that that it fits with both um
you know both what we were talking about
with regard to what Renee D rest is up
to uh the kinds of things the FCC is
trying to get its paw into with regard
to the powers that it would Grant itself
uh and then of course uh
what how is it that public displays of
anti-Semitism become normalized and
under what circumstances do they do so
well under precisely these circumstances
it is it is as as Barry suggested a
symptom and not that it doesn't feel
very much like the entire point and the
only point when you are experiencing it
um but um taking a step back and seeing
it as a symptom of something larger and
a predictable one at that uh is
critical yes um I would take a second
Point as well um which is I I think
increasingly is a fair term to use
increasingly uh criticisms of me which
as you point out are something we almost
never encounter in person um people are
very nice even when they disagree um
it's very rare that we get challenged
this way but online of course it happens
all the time
um increasingly there is a um
conspiratorial aspect to the
accusations and I must say I find it um
funny the conspiracies are so thin and
so weird in some cases oh like mad agent
Peter Teal's puppet Peter Teal's puppet
okay so my brother
uh is and was associated with Peter teal
right that's not me I have met Peter
teal and I have enjoyed talking with him
I
don't I don't think he's very fond of my
perspective it's certainly hard to
imagine that um he would be advancing it
in the world and it has certainly been I
don't know how many years since the last
time I spoke to him but anyway it's an
absurdity no but it's I mean it's it's
the same thing like you know you just
you put things that many people find um
uncomfortable or despicable or vaguely
icky next to one another and it causes
them to go like oh I don't know I don't
have time to look into it that oh I've
heard I've heard that that guy knows
this other guy and I don't like either
of them so enough said well my favorite
of these um is there's a uh a conspiracy
theory honestly I I can't even are you
sure it's not a conspiracy hypothesis
Brad oh no this is a
conspiracy theory unfalsifiable in fact
um that somehow connects my family to
the your natal family not this family
here correct yeah um to the Robert
Kennedy
assassination oh on the basis that my
dad worked for Bobby Kennedy in the
justice department and I'm not sure how
that yeah no working for with and on
behalf of the definitely means that you
hate him right that that's the that's
the leap um yeah and in fact um at one
point I was going to see Bobby and the
younger yes Bobby Kennedy Jr and uh yes
I was uh born a year after Bobby Kennedy
senior was killed um but anyway um I
introduced my dad to Bobby Kennedy Jr
and they talked about the fact that my
dad had worked for um uh for Bobby's
father um and so anyway the idea that
any connection at all any wisp of some
ancient connection is going to be turned
into some obviously conspiratorial
something is uh obviously a bad Instinct
that people have yeah no it sure is um I
did I I don't want to spend much time on
it and we're we're going to stop here
very quickly but I did want to say come
back to your point about the
normalization
of of of things in general so you were
talking about the normalization of
anti-Semitism and
um
the there's there's a there's a dust up
that we didn't talk about at all um
online in the wake of the Gen spect
conference uh which I mentioned in our
last live stream which I've written
about at Natural Selections um and it's
a piece that I call the public fetish uh
and it's about uh um autog gyil at the
Gen spect conference and specifically um
a man uh who uh you know identifies
himself as and again with this focus on
identity um as an autog gynophile finds
um finds that clarifying as a way to
understand what he is in life which is
to say someone who um is a heterosexual
male who has turned the focus of his
attraction inward so that he um wants to
be attracted Ed to himself as a as a
woman um has written a 700 page book on
the topic which he handed me at the
conference and uh and the conference
organizers or rather the the person uh
Manning I want to say womaning I'm not
going to start doing this with person
Manning the Twitter account for genp
treading dangerously close to a very
famous Monty Python routine which which
one the Life of Brian in which uh lorett
uh keeps um oh no that's that's
different that's different um yeah I'm
not going to start calling them like
woman hle covers and stuff but
um the person who mans the Twitter
account is actually a woman of course at
Jens spect um not of course but she is
um anyway the the people I'll say I
don't even know if it was the the person
I happen to know um behind the the
Twitter account posted a picture of Phil
the ayop file um and a young woman who's
a d transitioner together and said you
know spotted here uh and also Phil's got
this book out and all hell broke loose
uh because um According to some and I'm
not again I encourage you to go take a
look at what I've written and then you
can also go online and find all sorts of
stuff um online on Twitter and such um
but uh some people say you know what the
hell you know why would you contribute
to platforming such a person with such
delusions in a place especially where
there are Women and Children and Youth
who have been who are who are
experiencing trauma associated with
exactly this sort of delusion and then
there are are people who said um you
know this guy's not a creep he's not a
threat he knows what he is he doesn't
think he's a woman he doesn't use
women's facilities uh he is being honest
and forthright trying to understand what
he is um and I should say that at a
conference where everyone else was
dressed in you know conference clothes
um here's a tall thin man wearing a you
know blue velvet gown with long blue
gloves uh you know so there weren't any
other there weren't any women dressed
like that and there weren't any um other
men dressed like that uh and indeed no
one was in any kind of like fancy outfit
like that at all
um my argument in the piece that I wrote
in part
is no there shouldn't be laws against
this just as there shouldn't be laws
against speaking hatred about
Jews uh but we do have norms and Norms
do change and Norms should
change uh but some of the societal Norms
that we have had for a long
time uh are breaking down with regard to
um over in over in the space I'm talking
about now uh with regard to uh when
women can let down their guard and know
that they're safe and when they cannot
and so at the same moment that we are
being informed by the um insane gender
ideology that we must not trust our
instincts that we must you know if if we
see if we walk into a women's bathroom
and see a guy in there um we have to not
just be okay with that but celebrate it
and if any part of our spine starts to
tingle uh or our hackles are raised we
don't trust that because that would be
bigoted to do so and of course the truth
is exactly the opposite women have been
relying on our intuition about whether
or not the situation is safe forever and
it is what we must do and sometimes we
will be wrong but it is actually
incumbent upon us to be wrong in the
direction that keeps us more safe rather
than less not to treat the feelings of
someone else uh with more priority than
our potential safety that is actually
our responsibility as individuals and I
would say that and I did say in this
piece that I don't feel like this
particular individual I met him I talked
with him I did not I didn't have any
indication of creepiness at all and I
could be wrong but say I'm right
still the fact of walking around in
explicitly hyper like weirdly feminine
dress of which no one else is doing um
in a landscape where there are creeps
and predators doing exactly that and
using that to get access to women's
spaces and using the fact that women are
being told not to trust their intuitions
and to stand down and to embrace the
predator even the non creep who does
that helps to normalize that and and
helps create an environment of less
safety and so too uh does an Ever
greater environment in which people are
kind of just like playing with ideas of
anti-Semitism and this is not an
argument to legislate against at all
this is saying that actually we have
things besides laws that are social
norms and sometimes they need to change
and sometimes they were actually doing
something very important and as they
start to Decay it is incumbent upon us
to point it out and to say actually that
thing we were using that that was
necessary that was a a common good and
it's our right to fight to get it back
yeah it's actually um it's a Chester's
fence issue yeah in which the inability
to spell out exactly what the norm was
doing does not mean that it was not
doing something vital right and so we
are constantly you
know uh it's it's hard to even describe
what this
person was doing wrong right if uh if a
woman had showed up dressed wildly uh
differently than everybody else there
would obviously be no issue
um there wouldn't have
been a safety issue but it would have
been odd sure it would have been strange
it would have been a choice that was
being made to what to draw attention to
your yourself to like what why and you
know should you be allowed to do that I
guess um should you be encouraged to do
that should we embrace you for doing
that no uhuh no no of course not but um
the point is we all have the you know
except in the case where there is an
enforced dress code right we all are
granted a certain amount of leeway about
how to interpret the environment and
what the correct style of dress is and
we all encounter people all the time who
are out of phase with what we would do
in their shoes sure and you don't want
to live in a society where we do the
opposite where we regulate these things
so that normal
leeway finds itself
um wickedly abused by some and uh abused
but with no obvious ill intent by others
in the case of your autophile
um that you know you said you didn't
find he's not
mine you and your conferences Auto kind
of files um but the problem is the fact
that you can't spell out exactly where
the line is that he's over doesn't say
that there wasn't a line and doesn't say
that that line wasn't important and well
I mean there there's also I mean we we
we could go on at some at some length
here
um there's also a question so an autog
gynophile has said um what what he has
said and and people are now interpreting
what autophilia is in all of these ways
and frankly it is a mental condition
which is
bizarre and uh and it
is most of us do
not display our sexual desires in public
and he could be this he could have this
identity and keep it to himself yep but
the idea that in order to have this
identity
fulfilled he needs to have other people
see
it uh makes it something that all the
rest of us get to comment on and have
distinct opinions about and
furthermore uh you know so when he
actually when he approached me um he
started saying autog gynophile Auto
androphile I'm like Auto androphile is
that going to be like the symmetrical
version where a woman who is a straight
woman who sees herself as a man and that
turns her on he's like yes I'm like I'm
I don't I don't buy like maybe
occasionally but um in so far as I get
the autophile thing at all and I don't
Intuit it at all but in so far as I get
it just like male and female
homosexuality are radically different
and come from different places so too is
the sense of like actually should be the
sex that I'm not going to come from very
different places and I think that it's
probably true that autog gyil to the
extent it's a real thing does explain
some amount of male to
female transness um but I think it's
going to be a extraordinarily rare thing
over in female to male space and so it's
that that this this constant searching
for symmetry for um for not just equal
treatment but identical treatment and I
would say that this absolutely applies
FES over in fashion space as well so
traditionally female dress and I said
this online as well not in the piece but
I made some extended answers to to
Twitter questions about this piece um
traditional female dress is Impractical
and silly right and the fact is that
it's been decades 100 year like a long
time now that it's been understood that
women um can adopt what has been
traditionally mail dress because women
who aren't impractical and silly should
be allowed to dress in ways that aren't
impractical and silly as well right
and therefore women dressing in ways
that were traditionally male is almost
never like you have you have to stretch
it to imagine like oh that's a sexual
thing yeah oh you're doing that because
like no I just want to be able to move
my legs and not risk exposing myself
like I want to be able to garden and
bike and you know do all the things that
actually men have always been able to do
and women's fashion was another way that
we were manifest is like
decorative ornaments right so when men's
and you know on a very hot day a skirt
might be cooler and Kilts exist and you
know more feminine clothing exists flowy
clothing exists for men and some men
adopt it and it is clearly about
responding to the environment but this
particular like I see myself as a woman
and therefore I'm going to dress in
something that almost no Modern Woman
would ever put on and certainly not in
this
circumstance is inherently about a about
regressive tropes of what it is to be
you know it's like Desiring to be that
decorative object as opposed to
understanding much about what the Sexes
actually are well I mean at the risk of
going someplace that we've we've been
here before here um to me and forgive me
if you if you said this in your piece
but um the issue with this in particular
ular person is actually weirdly one of
consent because he is in this
environment bringing people in on his
own yes sexual
fantasy and the point is well this is a
conference of people there to talk about
ideas and the thing that's wrong with it
is that he's turning it into a sexual
thing nobody can tell him not to but the
point is the norm says actually that's
not cool right that's not that's not
acceptable behavior for for what this
environment is and the contrast I would
draw yeah I assume that uh neither Blair
white uh nor um Buck Angel Buck Angel
were at the conference right um but had
they been my sense is that actually they
would be in a position to shed an awful
lot of light on things that others will
have to speculate about and that because
they have both been EX ellent at um
drawing these distinctions in a way that
is uh totally protective of the rights
of women and the rights of children K
con was there yeah and and she does a
very good job so anyway my point is you
know the fact that that uh Blair looks
like a woman and that buck looks like a
man um I don't
think I don't think they would be
crossing a line present even though you
know especially you know I guess in both
their cases they're sort of you know
they've elaborated characteristics that
are traditionally uh female and male
um so anyway the question is is it
really the sexual aspect of this that
puts it beyond the pale and you know the
issue of consent is dicey because we
don't typically police what's in
people's minds well but I
mean we do sometimes right and you I and
I've said intent actually does matter
and so again putting on on a skirt
because it's really really hot out yeah
is different from putting on a skirt
because it turns you on to be seen in a
skirt or to see yourself in a skirt and
if it's just to see yourself in a skirt
then fine stay inside yeah but if you're
going out into public in it then you
have you have said that there is
something preferent about this that you
need eyes on you and therefore those
eyes cannot possibly have consented to
you dragging your own fantasy world into
into their lives uh and it's it's a it's
a different situation um so intent
matters consent matters
we do like the various kinds of you know
manslaughter and murder are about intent
y right so it's not that we never try to
get into the minds of the people oh
that's not what I'm saying obviously
intent matters with respect to
uh uh sexual
desire we don't typically police the
content of people's minds now I will
argue that we actually make a mistake
it's not that we should be policing the
content of people's minds but it's it's
very different uh if we say actually
certain fantasies aren't cool and to the
extent that you're fantasizing about
them that's bad I think we should
actually be doing that a lot more
there's a lot of stuff that people are
getting off on that is spilling over
into the world that is not good and
that's not the same thing as we want to
know what you're fantasizing about and
we want to police it but the idea that
we should say actually you know what
some of this stuff is not healthy and
you shouldn't be doing it and you know
getting off on people looking at you
crossdressing at a conference that you
know is an I don't know exactly how to
describe it but an analytical space is
well and specifically a space where you
know there were so many parents there
whose whose children are suffering from
the delusion at the moment and are you
know are in the process of perhaps
rendering them infertile for life and
you just you know are precisely in the
middle of the chaos and I think think
Phil um the uh the autog whom we've been
talking about um believes that he is
helping such people by revealing that
actually this condition explains many
maletto female uh trans people um but I
don't I guess there's a way in which and
and I'm seeing this more and more and
more that people are reaching for
diagnosis and once they have diagnosis
they think they've got it
and God if Co didn't teach the world
anything like yeah you know how many
times does medicine and do do
psychologists and does everyone have to
be just wrong before you start saying
you know what just because you've got a
label for the thing doesn't mean that
that label is right that everything that
looks kind of like that goes into that
label or that once you have the label
you know what to do because the the even
even if even if the C ategory has been
correctly described by say the
DSM and and um and you really do fit
that diagnosis that still doesn't help
you very much it's not it's not a
resolution it's like I don't know why
people land there and go like I I know
why I think um and it is
a oversimplification of biology it is an
incorrect oversimplification of biology
where once you've got a DI nois it feels
immutable a you're not responsible for
it and B there's nothing you can do
about it so who who is society to tell
you not to XY and z and the answer is no
the fact that um you have a
diagnosis doesn't mean it's not the
result of you having or Society having
tolerated something in you that it
should have discouraged right and it
doesn't mean that there's nothing you
can do about it so um I think the point
is it's just uh it's sloppy excuse
making um
for stuff that you know
a well I don't so sloppy excuse making I
don't think is is fair I think that may
be actually what's going on but
people people are I I I think this goes
back to this move from when we were
coming of age everyone was looking for
meaning and now everyone is looking for
identity Y and as part of you need to
know what you are what your identity is
there is a focus on diagnosis on you
know what what are the five things that
describe you right and you know
certainly there's always been there's
always been some of that but
uh I saw and you know this is be going
to be a big can of worms and I don't
think maybe I'll just say it maybe we
come back to
it but I heard from a number of people
smart
people courageous
honest honorable people who really felt
that they had unraveled um not like a
lot of women like I I must have talked
to like six different people who had the
experience of I thought I women I
thought I was trans but then it turns
out I wasn't I was
autistic
and autism as we have talked about is
not one thing it can't possibly be that
the kid banging his head on the wall in
the corner who will never have language
is the same thing as the high
functioning uh people on the Spectrum
who we had in our classrooms and you
know are you know prevalent in you know
higher reaches of all kinds of
professional Fields right it's just like
what why are we putting those on the
same in the same place but also we're
now hearing well it manifests very very
differently in men and women that that
may well be true but maybe actually
we're dealing with a whole lot of
different things and there's a whole lot
of little clusters of things that happen
because we are polluting our environment
and we're polluting your minds when
you're growing up by putting you in
front of screens and by not letting you
go outside and by not enforcing um
social interaction uh without adults uh
being intermediaries and solving all
your problems for you and and you've
grown up confused and sheltered and
hurting and you're looking for a
diagnosis to explain why you're confused
and sheltered and hurting and you are
brave and wise enough to have pulled
yourself out of the Tails spin that was
trans but you still want some diagnosis
and the still want some diagnosis means
that you're still buying the thing a
little bit and I'm not saying that
autism isn't real uh or that this may
not explain some of it but it feels like
you're still in the grip of being able
to be told ah not that but this and when
you maybe come out of that you go like
not that but this and maybe actually
really understanding all of the things
that went into the developmental
environment that made you who you are
and back to your point like there's just
a failure to recognize what humans are
we've got the longest childhoods on the
planet and that's not a mistake
this is when we become human and we are
collectively as a society that
up like we are just messing with
children so badly at every level no
wonder people are hurting and confused
and looking for a diagnosis but maybe a
diagnosis won't help maybe actually
saying you know what I'm a human being
and I'm me an individual and I'm either
male or female and other than that
there's almost nothing that's binary in
biology and let's go let's figure out
how to make the most of this and make
some meaning on this beautiful planet we
have while we still have
it um couple things one I think this
idea that you need a diagnosis to free
you from a diagnosis is really important
yeah um I I think that is a lot of
what's going on and the the problem is
we don't have language for uh yeah I
thought I was trans and it turns out
that's not true well then what is true
you know well the answer is most people
who have U dysphoria gender dysphoria
get over it yeah so the point is that's
a matter of development correcting
itself um and it's the obvious best path
right the idea of a life on
Pharmaceuticals Downstream of surgeries
that don't actually create the condition
that you think you want right they
simulate it at
best but the other thing and I just want
to unpack the piece that you were saying
about our developmental periods because
I don't think this is where people just
don't they oversimplify the biology in a
way that's very destructive the reason
that we have the longest developmental
periods of not only any creature on the
planet but any creature that has ever
been on this planet is because there is
a very long period of time necessary to
build up the structures of a highly
functional adult human being right on
the one hand that gives us our amazing
flexibility the idea that you live a
very different life than uh a a Mayan
farmer or astronomer priest is the
result of the fact that you're not
pre-programmed for your Niche but that's
an awful lot of time for stuff to go
wrong and the fact is it going right is
more or less dependent on an environment
that looks a lot like the one that your
ancestors lived in so that they know how
to raise you and expose you to dangers
at the right rate and all that and you
know just look around you look at your
environment it doesn't look any anything
like any ancestor lived in including
your own parents right it's that
different that quickly y so um of course
we're screwing people up and you know we
were going to fix one thing right to get
to all the others fixing it so that your
childhood had a coherent relationship to
the adult environment you were going to
be in so that you knew how to be an
adult in it would be the uh biggest bang
for the buck alteration we could make
absolutely um one more Point um
with regard to uh autism and people
becoming very focused on actually that's
what I am that's what I have we began to
see this when we were at Evergreen we
began to have more and more students who
would come to us say I'm aspie I'm like
I'm on spectrum and um I began to see it
and like I could I could see it in some
of these people and be like yeah I I see
what you're talking about right um the
one one thing that makes me think um
okay um maybe maybe this is actually
much more prevalent uh than I am
thinking like maybe this isn't just a
like hopping diagnosis to diagnosis
thing is as far as I know and I'd like
to hear it if I'm wrong I don't think uh
there is a proposed pharmaceutical
solution I don't think that people with
this diagnosis end up on drugs uh which
means that the usual perverse Financial
incentives don't exist for this that's a
good point that's a good point I think I
think it's right and I do think um
autism has skyrocketed for whatever
reason right um that and I you know as
you as you said it doesn't appear to be
one thing it's hard to imagine how the
the banging your head on the wall thing
uh is the same as the super high
functioning techniek thing right um
could be could be like the relationship
of uh Parkinson's to uh what is the name
of the syndrome where you're totally
100% paralyzed shut in syndrome locked
in syndrome oh yeah yeah um you know
those things apparently do have a
relationship yeah um but or it could be
like we think like schizophrenia like oh
that's a lot of different things that
all just look like oh you're really
crazy um but there's a number of things
going on there yeah um but anyway uh it
could be that autistic people because
something is off and because they you
know the high functioning autistic folks
can detect maybe even are hyper
sensitive to how far off things are that
they're looking for some very big off
thing and so they're very suscep to the
idea that oh you know what it is you
were born in the wrong body like oh my
God that would make sense of just how
off things feel right um and a yeah so
they made me more susceptible to having
made an error about identity in the
first place right you know so so landing
on autism as an accurate diagnosis may
actually be an endpoint after uh
diagnosis of identity that were in error
actually I'm going to add one more thing
here um which you will know the
background of but I am a color deficient
in common parlament color blind and I
don't have uh it's not standard red
green color blindness it's a weird one
can I add a add a point from earlier
today sure yes uh I came in and uh was
literally wearing two gloves of
different colors and denied that when I
pointed it
out yeah yes I could not see that one of
them was purple in fact I must have
bought purple purple gloves thinking
that they were black and the one thing
that I said was you cannot go on air
wearing it is possible that you also
discount your own sense of um what
you're like right and so to the extent
that there are people out there selling
a story um that oh I you know I think
you're born in the wrong body um that
may be more likely to persuade somebody
who is discounting their own ability to
perceive accurately where they are in
the world yeah um I wonder about no that
I actually I have I have I've seen that
before before these last few weeks I've
seen that as something parents saying my
child was definitely autistic my child
was definitely you know
not understanding all of the influences
on them in the world and uh and was uh
was minimizing some of them at least
consciously and that made them more
susceptible yeah yeah I could I could
easily see it to the to the trans thing
yeah
all right well um boy that went a lot of
places yes it did all right um so we are
not going to do a Q&A today we'll be
back in eight days we'll be back the day
before Thanksgiving for our 200th
episode and I don't know what we'll talk
about then actually I know one of the
things we'll talk about then but uh
we'll save it for then all right okay so
uh we haven't been we haven't been as
much on locals lately but um locals is
going strong and we're going to we're
going to get back on there ourselves
soon we encourage you to please please
join there there's been um chat watch
party while we're doing the live streams
for rumble the guest episodes that Brett
um hosts uh come out on Rumble a day
early I guess that doesn't help with
locals um we do our private Q&A on
locals what's that they come out on
locals today early okay um and uh we do
our private Q&A our monthly Q&A on
locals as well we do we have done some
am uh as well so please join us there um
um check out my writing including the
piece we're just talking about the
public fetish at natural selections.
sub.com
we've got um great merchandise at
darkhorse.com pizza and that is why you
are not wearing a mask if you live in
one of those places where masks are on
the uptech which is remarkable they are
many places you want to get one of these
shirts in time for the uptick that is
undoubtedly headed your way yeah yeah
yeah so we last year um sometime between
Thanksgiving and Christmas we did a like
a gift episode just an additional bonus
episode um I think we'll do that again
um in which we then talked about some of
the merchandise that we've got but uh
but it's all up there now uh we'll get a
couple more pieces a couple more things
up um before couple more slices couple
more slices micro Pizza Jake's micro
Pizza someone at the genp conference
talked to me about Jake's micro Pizza I
was so pleased look the thing is once
you've tried it you realize that you've
been eating you know lackluster Pizza
your whole life you don't know that
until youve TR I mean so you know maybe
people should be careful about trying
Jake's micro Pizza cuz cuz you never go
back addictive yeah it is for sure yeah
it's not deep dish though not yet
they're still working on that Jake's
micro deep dish pizza exactly yep
okay
um
yeah else to say about that
um okay check out also our sponsors this
week which were seed uncruise and mind
Bloom I think is what that says that
says um we're going to put links to
everything we talked about here in the
show notes as always and a reminder that
we are supported by you our audience for
which we're super super grateful Bobcats
and links uh it's spelled differently as
he damn well knows why that
matters if I could put links in the show
notes I'd keep them myself you would I
would absolutely totally yeah I guess if
I could put links in the show not I
would keep it to myself yeah yes yeah
I'll share the links plural and I'll
keep the link singular to myself
excellent mhm um all right uh please
share subscribe like all these things um
and we're putting Clips out on Twitter
now um so join the Darkhorse uh Twitter
Channel thing what is it called the
Darkhorse what's a Twitter thing called
uh it's not a channel a dark course
account there you go I joined that and
until we see you next time be good to
the ones you love eat good food and get
outside be well
[Music]
everyone